he may have friends in high places but
they couldn't help garth brooks open the
legion stadium
today the singer announced his concert
to open the venue next month has been
postponed
brooks says instead now the show will be
february 27
2021 but again at allegion stadium until
then brooks says he and his team are
doing their best
to keep people entertained they're
planning even more drive-in and virtual
shows
vr is the natural next step as far as
people getting to experience a concert
because we've all experienced concerts
if we're lucky from
the audience side would you experience
that from the drummer's
point of view it'll blow your mind so i
want that experience for anybody that
might
follow garth stuff and so that's
probably where we're going to turn the
page next
doing what you got to do if you bought
tickets to the concert at allegion
stadium they will be honored for this
new show in february but if you didn't
get a ticket well you're out of luck
all 65 000 tickets sold out already in
less than two hours